من هنا من العلا شمال غرب المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في اكبر متحف مفتوح في العالم
وايضا ضمن فعاليات شتاء طنطوره وفعاليات
العلا التي تجري هنا نتحدث عن مهرجان
الحمضيات فباكثر من 200,000 شجره مثمره
تزدهر زراعه الحمضيات بواحات العلا في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هذه الزراعه
التي اصبحت احد اشهر المنتجات التي تقدمها
المنطقه الغنيه ايضا باشجار النخيل
الزائده عن مليوني شجره فضلا عن اشجار
البان العربي الشهيره هنا ولكن ماذا عن
زراعه الحمضيات في العلا سنتعرف اكثر في
تقرير التالي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم تطل عليكم في صباح العربيه في
مهرجان الحمضيات بنسخته الثانيه هنا في
العلا هذا المهرجان الذي يضم اكشاكا
باصناف وانواع الحمضيات على اختلافها التي
تاتي من اشجار العلا نتحدث عن اكثر من 200
الف شجره مزدهره هنا في العلا بفعل المياه
الوفيره وايضا التربه
[موسيقى]
يقام المهرجان في موسم الحصاد ليتمتع
الضيوف بتذوق اشهى انواع الحمضيات الطازجه
المنتجه في مزارع العلا محليا وتحت اشراف
الهيئه الملكيه لمحافظه العلا والتي قررت
عقد هذا المهرجان بشكل سنوي خلال شهر
يناير تزامنا مع موسم الحصاد والتصليط
الضوء ايضا داخليا وخارجيا على منتجات
العلا من الحمضيات ودعم تسويق المنتجات
الفريده لحمضيات العلا
[موسيقى]
الحمضيات ايضا تدخل في صناعه الحلويات
والماكولات فمثلا لدينا هنا كعكه بنكهه
الليمون وهذه عجينه بنكهه البرتقال وايضا
كعكه اخرى بنكهه البرتقال سنتذوقها الان
في صباح العربيه ولكن قبل ذلك نريد ان
نحتسي القهوه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
معكم مع احد اقدم حمضيات العلا انه الترنج
حيث تشير الدراسات الى انه تم استخدامه في
الطب الشعبي وتطويره عبر طرق التهجير من
قبل الحضاره النبطيه كنا معكم في مهرجان
الحمضيات من العلا من الخماش لصباح
العربيه
[موسيقى]
اذا كان هذا جانب من تغطيه مهرجان
الحمضيات في العلا وهذا المهرجان الذي
يستمر على مده ثلاثه اسابيع من شهر يناير
من السادس من يناير حتى الحادي والعشرين
من يناير سيكون في عطله نهايه الاسبوع
يعني كل اسبوع على مدار ثلاثه اسابيع طبعا
نحن نقف الان ونجلس في هذا الاستديو
المفتوح في العلا من محاطون بانواع مختلفه
بالحمضيات وسنكون ايضا مع ضيفنا السيد
محمد الجود صاحب مزرعه استاذ محمد يعطيك
العافيه
اهلا وسهلا صباح العربيه
[موسيقى]
جزء لا يتجزء من هويه العلا ثقافه العلا
حتى اهل العلم
والله الان ما شاء الله تبارك الرحمن الان
صارت البرتقال ما شاء الله صار عندنا
انتاج قويه في محافظه العلا وسار يمثل لنا
السوق صار التجار تجينا من خارج محافظه
العلا
وتسوقوا عندنا في مهرجان الحمضيات في
سوى لنا جانب كم مزارعين جانب كثير جدا
همم للتجار لانهم يجون الا محافظه العلا
وما شاء الله تبارك الرحمن يعني صار عندنا
اهتمام الان الزياده في المزارع ااا
بالنسبه للبرتقال والحمضيات عامه
وسار الانتاج
وفر جدا ما شاء الله تبارك الرحمن
محليين هون فيها المناطق وتصيروا عالميين
يعني يجوا التجار من حول العالم حتى
يشوفوا كل هذه المنتوجات التي تنتجها
مزارعكم في العراق
[موسيقى]
محافظه المملكه العربيه السعوديه عامه
وممثل ابو محافظه العلا لانها همم طلع همم
المزارع والتطويرها وصار الانتاج لانها
قريبنا نبيع البرتقال على همم المناطق
ساره الان هم يجوا عندنا
وساره العامه المنطقه صارت انها ثريه
وساره الشباب يساعدوا انهم يطورهم ويطورون
الاشياء هذه الملكيه
الاخيره اثناء مواجهه الاولى رفعت الانتاج
ورفعت الشباب الدعم العام لهم
فخلتنا نطور من زرعتنا لا اكثر ولاحسن ان
شاء الله
اذا انا بدي اجي على مزرعتك مزرعه الجود
وتقول لي تنصحني بشو انا اخذ من الحمضيات
يعني احنا هلا في امامنا انواع شويه
مختلفه عن بعض انا بعرف البرتقال اشهرها
بس شو بدك تنصحني تقول لي هاي ليفهوتك هون
الحلو
الليمون الحلو هو تشتهر في العلم من زمان
[موسيقى]
انه
اساسا من منطقه العلا
بعدها يجينا البرتقال ولسوف افندي
وجميع انواع الحمضيات بس اساسا عندنا اللي
هو البرتقاله الحلو هذا البرتقاله الحلو
اساسا من اهل من منطقه العلا
وعامه احنا قديمين يعني في زراعه عن
الوالد و رحمه الله عليه هو اللي كان يزرع
الحمضيات ويعلمنا كيف نطعمها يمكن هو من
احد المزارعين الاولين في محافظه العلا ت
همم زراعه الحمضيات والمرتقال همم والحمد
لله الان صارت عندنا مزرعه كبيره البرتقال
والحمضيات
يعني استاذ محمد فكره انه العيله تتوارث
الاهتمام بالمزرعه كيف شو اللي بيعني هذا
لكم وكيف تتاسوا وكافراد عيله ادوار
الاهتمام يعني مثلا انت دورك هيك
قريبك دورها هيك ابنك دوره هيك كيف
صارت المزرعه ممزعه في ناس مسؤوله عن اسم
مسؤوله عن الاهتمام في نفس المزرعه ناس
مهتمين في التسويق زي كذا كل واحد له همم
بالعكس المزرعه ان هي اللي تجمع العائله
يعني هي اللي تجمع العائله اللي تلقى اخر
الاسبوع يكون فيها جميعا
ويهتموا فيها يعني الاهتمام منها اول شيء
اهم حاجه هي الجمعه وكل من يتوزع له
الدوره الاهتمام همم اجانب همم
المنسوب له
يعني احنا بنشكرك كثير انه جئتنا وشرفتنا
اليوم ويعطيك الف عافيه وبالتوفيق دايما
محمد الجود احد مزارع مزرعه الجود شكرا لك